[Music]
it may be hard to imagine the day-to-day
stress
experienced by police officers and the
effect on mental
and physical health and it may be
equally hard to grasp the shock and
trauma of being mistreated by police
well one man we encountered has had both
experiences
now he's found a way to come to terms
with these events finding a measure of
inner peace
and sharing it with the world one two
top gilliam is leading a fight for
fitness
right here co-founding a workout studio
in orange new jersey
just before the pandemic hit
outdoors and now socially distanced he
combines boxing
and yoga slowly
to help clients achieve balance and body
mind
and spirit i'm strong i'm healthy
they started to call me the zen boxer
finding peace came out of his days as a
peace officer with the plainfield new
jersey police department
he joined in 2009 when he was 23.
my dad was a police officer about 26
years retired as a captain i have an
uncle
that just retired last year from the new
jersey state police so they both
inspired me to be police officers
i was ahead of the class i left the
academy class
with a few different awards i won the
driving award i had won the physical
training
red brick award excellent duty awards so
i was in
good standing throughout the the first
two years
but while celebrating a birthday with
his girlfriend in 2010 gilliam was
arrested
outside a nightclub in the town of
bloomfield new jersey
somebody throws and spits something into
my vehicle so i was violated
i got out of my driver's side i went
over to this officer with the intent
to ask for service he looks at me stops
me like whoa
wait wait a second like where are you
coming from so i'm like all right
look i'm a police officer as well then
it seemed like that triggered something
he gets upset
looks me up and down you're getting
arrested two officers grab me i'm not
resisting at all i get placed in
handcuffs somebody slams my head up
against the door
they start punching me all over my body
i go into police department
completely humiliated the officers
involved
dispute his description but two years
later
a jury acquitted him of assault on a
police officer
and resisting arrest a trial judge
however found him guilty of driving
while intoxicated
a charge he still denies he sued
bloomfield police for using
excessive force and settled out of court
he returned to his job for another three
years
i was immediately asked to come back to
work and that's how i started back it
was like all right
right back here's your bulletproof vest
here's your gun let's go shoot
no time to process no time to process
anything the time to
decompress yeah what did that do to you
it was difficult
i was definitely a different officer i
listened to orders and did all that
people act and i wanted to give my best
effort
of being a police officer but then you
see things that happen
on the job that's just you know are
wrong
and i wasn't the extreme case to to snap
but it gets to that point yoga helped
you through that
absolutely because it helped me regulate
my emotions and regulate
my mental and be with with myself and
accept what is
gilliam was in therapy but had trouble
healing until a friend of his suggested
trying yoga
all too often we hear the stories of
people that don't come out on the other
side
he made it his full-time job in 2019
teaming with retired verizon executive
michelle swintenberg to start
brawl studio it stands for be relentless
with life
for someone to go through what he went
through
and then come through it and still want
to help other people
i think that speaks a lot to the person
that he is
hey there we go come on bang bang
so martis has a calm actually he has
this it's
what i love is the boxing and the yoga
together there's so much going on right
now
outside of our heads yoga i think gives
you a moment to
breathe to connect with the breath which
i think just in our fast-paced lives we
don't get to do
that signature combo boxing and yoga
speaks volumes yes
in the beginning of class i'm taking you
up getting the heart rate up you give
all the effort
that you can want you to feel as strong
as you possibly can
and then you're sweaty and then i get
you to connect to your heart
people bring their palms together and i
would say certain affirmations that if
it doesn't challenge you it doesn't
change you
like your love your kindness and
compassion all come from your heart
but your courage your bravery your
strength all come from the same place
all right i want the energy up you
wouldn't have that mindset without the
yoga you'd be all in fight mode
this allows you to take out that
aggression and then bring that
level of calmness inhale in
and release without it where would you
be without
finding a practice i don't know where i
would be i would probably be depressed i
would probably
may have been one of the people to snap
or go off i wouldn't
be in a place where i'm at peace and and
enjoy this 34 year old believes it can
help in
healing and training officers who
protect and serve
double time one twos i want the best for
police officers
i truly feel that the training is
setting officers up for my experience
to not win i truly believe that some
type of
martial arts discipline practice and
yoga practice
consistently throughout your entire
career can help a person
just regulate their emotions for police
officers or police officers
for anyone i think that being trained
gives you a certain confidence that you
don't need to go grabbing for your gun
and and that's the key you know i first
heard martisa's story about two years
ago when
i took one of his classes uh and when i
when i saw what happened to george floyd
i
immediately i immediately thought of him
and remember that dave chappelle
um 848 46 stand up that he did
he talked about how police officers who
had seen bad
things done and then reported them what
happened to them some of them being
fired from the force and how they took
it internally and and snapped as a
result that's what he was describing he
says
i don't want my fellow officers my
former fellow officers
to have to go through this it would be
so wonderful if they found what i
found and so that's why i thought it was
important to tell us yeah and i love
that he also
says for anyone not just for police but
certainly you can see that i mean you've
taken yoga i know
yeah and actually i wish that class was
here in new york because boxing and yoga
combined you're right the woman in the
piece that said you get that aggression
out
and then you center yourself let's do it
all right